THAT HE ACTUALLY DROVE A STAKE
THROUGH.
>> Tucker: MARK STEYN,
THANK YOU.
AS YOU JUST HEARD AND IF YOU SAW
IT, YOU KNEW, THE RALLY WAS AN
UPBEAT EVENT.
IT'S GOOD NEWS, THE PRESIDENT IS
NOT A TRAITOR.
BUT THE NEWS IS A DISASTER FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
DEMOCRATS ARE PLANNING TO READ
THAT CONSPIRACY THEORY TO
VICTORY IN THE ELECTION NEXT
YEAR.
THEY WERE SO CERTAIN THAT TRUMP
WAS GUILTY OF COLLUSION THAT
THEY INSTALLED THEIR PARTY'S
CHIEF COLLUSION MONGER AT THE
HEAD FUND-RAISER FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS.
ADAM SCHIFF WAS PLANNING TO
SPEND THE NEXT 18 MONTHS WRITING
DIRECT MAIL PIECES ABOUT
ESPIONAGE AND THE KREMLIN AND
DON JR. GOING TO JAIL.
ROBERT MUELLER FOILED HIS PLANS
BUT NOW, HE'S BACK ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEES.
AND, HE IS NONE OF THOSE THINGS.
NO MATTER HOW ABSURD, HE DOESN'T
BELIEVE AND REPEATS
WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
>> THERE IS SIGNIFICANCE
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION, THERE IS
AMPLE EVIDENCE, AND INDEED THERE
IS, OF COLLUSION OF PEOPLE IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
THERE'S PLENTY OF EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION AND CONSPIRACY.
>> THAT REPORT HAS BEEN TOUGH ON
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SAID THINGS LIKE
THAT.
YOU MIGHT THINK THEY WOULD BE
HIDING UNDER THE BED OR BEGGING
FOR FORGIVENESS, OR AT LEAST NOT
SAYING ANYTHING FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS.
BUT NO, THEY ARE STILL TALKING.
ADAM SCHIFF IS FIRST AMONG THEM.
HE BELIEVES IN COLLUSION AS
FERVENTLY AS HE EVER HAS.
CONSPIRACY IS TRUE.
>> FROM THE PUBLIC, YOU MIGHT
THINK IT'S OKAY.
YOU MIGHT THINK THAT'S OKAY.
I THINK IT'S IMMORAL, I THINK
IT'S UNETHICAL, I THINK IT'S
UNPATRIOTIC AND YES, I THINK
IT'S CORRUPT.
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
>> Tucker: ON IMMORAL,
UNETHICAL AND UNPATRIOTIC.
HE WENT ON AND ON LIKE A MENTAL
PATIENT SCREENING A CAR IS IN AN
INTERSECTION.
AT ONE POINT HE POINTED TO
WIKILEAKS AS PROOF OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
THE INTEL COMMITTEE HANDLES MOST
OF THE INFORMATION OUR
GOVERNMENT PRODUCES, IT'S NOT A
PLACE FOR CRAZY PEOPLE.
NOT A GOOD IDEA TO HAVE ONE OF
THE HOME.
HE'S NOT MENTALLY COMPETENT FOR